I'm trying to be more I know I go to the
comedy store and I talk to doorman
before I used to go what's up fatty
you're like Dylan he's a fat gay guy but
you faithful to come like just so mean
you know man when you cry just come come
out of your eyes you're just like real
mean yeah you know I mean it's at this
time now it's like how are you how was
your Christmas do you feel like you're
working there you actually enjoying the
conversation I'm trying to connect with
everyone even fans you know when people
come up to me I'm oh god something
happened terrible terrible
yes if you're listening ma'am ma'am
lady you're so cute let me say something
okay I go up on stage last week it's
dark in the o.r right and there's a girl
wearing a tiger belly t-shirt in the
front row okay but it's so dark that it
looks like a dude at first with long
hair so what's up bro I like the tiger
belly t-shirt what do you mean bro I'm a
girl and then I blushed so sorry and the
whole set I thought about it I'd even go
back I'd even go back to her and go it
was so dark in here
like you know that's that's not
offensive like I've been called
mistakenly like a dude my whole eye if
it wasn't wearing a tiger Bella t-shirt
I wouldn't give a [ __ ] I know don't
think that's something you should feel
bad because she allowed you to forget
about it just move on sorry because it
didn't i'm sure didn't affect her at all
yeah but here's what it is is is that
you're more tender it's not that it's I
just feel so much shame like I don't
want to hurt people's feelings because
and I think it's here we go but with the
[ __ ] therapy again but you know I
caught I was I lived through so much
right that whenever I and I vowed never
to be like my dad growing up I vowed I
remember praying and you really believed
in God but as keep going up so much
right and I know everyone to be like him
right so that when I when I perceive
that hurt anyone's feelings I get overly
sensitive and I get overly like you know
mean I need to fix this right
and that's so unhealthy right it's just
like move on Bob you made a mistake it's
like whenever I make a mistake I punish
myself I can't do that anymore
so keep the [ __ ] everything in I said
even the [ __ ] blue camel oh not oh
[ __ ] all right keep it all in right what
she did I what I forgot to say this why
are you attacking I wanna taste say then
that you [ __ ] up on oh I was so Rachel
what this is Carla no yeah I'm gonna
tell you what are there sweating this is
the first time you know you know what it
is I'm gonna tell you when I tell you
what it is you know what it is it's
proud